so tell me about mentality okay for a
minute winning in business winning in
property winning in life just in general
a lot of it is your mentality yes it's
knowledge is important but it's about
having the right attitude and
perspective to business what would you
say are the key differences between
having a winning and a losing mentality
positivity thinking of yourself already
in abundance if I want something I get
it because I've worked hard for it I had
my first job when I was 12 I love it
I've always wanted to be an
international business woman I did that
you know cuz that was the dream yeah my
dream now is just like property you know
I can just see the zeros it's really
about succeeding in myself right that's
what it is you know and I believe in the
Law of Attraction you know even little
things like someone asked how your day
was if you say I'm not so bad bad is a
negative words you know so just
literally seeing it and believing in it